I'm just back from the White Dinner party in Paris where I had a lot of fun.
Unlike last year where I only took photos, this time I also participated.
What a thrill!
I received my instructions from my contact.
There is no central organizer, at least nobody knows him...
...but only contacts of contacts.
I was supposed to join my group at 9:00 p.m. in front of a church.
Around 9:15 p.m.,...
...someone who obviously knew where the dinner was going to take place...
...took the group to the Champs Elysees!
Within the blink of an eye,...
...the whole lower part of the avenue was covered in tables, chairs, candles...
...and people dressed in white.
Fascinating!
Around 10:00 p.m., a band started to play music...
...and at 11:00 p.m. sharp, everyone lit sparkling sticks.
Beautiful!
Magical moment, even if the weather was a little chilly.